liebe leute der frühling hat begonnen
aber temperaturmäßig sieht das noch
ziemlich anders aus nämlich minus 33
grad in deutschland nachts in diesen
tagen aber das ist glaube ich genau der
richtige zeitpunkt um wen einzuladen den
- menschen eine der größten fanseiten
auf facebook mit bald 500.000 fans
kümmern dann feiern wie es dazu gekommen
der oder diejenigen hinter der seite die
können nicht singen die schauspieler
nicht die haben nicht mal ein youtube
kanal
wie kommt es dass eine fanseite so groß
wird das ist eine der vielen fragen an
den - menschen und hoffentlich noch eine
menge von euch die ihr in die kommentare
schreiben könnt oder am besten noch als
video antwort hochladen könnt ich bin
gespannt lest den info text lasst euch
was einfallen und dann will ich mal
sagen
bis dann bleibt dran